you know one challenge to do in the news
these days is not treating the war like
every other story as entertainment here
we make the news entertaining perhaps
better than any show that ever came
before it largely due to me
and that our competition over at cnn is
as fun as a case of crabs and not the
ones that are delicious with melted
butter
but now we run head first into daily
atrocity and i don't mean facing a
hungover cat in the hallway
ukraine is war and it's ugly with grim
imagery and relentless horror stories
but the news requires standard
narratives and if you veer off the
beaten track god help you other issues
demanded the same solemn treatment isis
pandemic death tolls a kamala harris
speech i mean what about the
significance of the passage of time am i
right
you know the significance of the passage
of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time and there is such great
significance to the passage of time
she is truly a national treasure if by
treasure you mean
embarrassment
but you know bad news often becomes
relentless news
and i get your mail and i get your
tweets so i understand
but the news dictates the mood it's like
those mass shootings we stop everything
to go live to the scene and we repeat
the same 90 seconds of information
mainly because it's all the information
that we have available it's not the
reporter's fault it's the unstoppable
predictability of the editorial loop
so it's the number of injured dead
location city shooter repeat then comes
the coverage of the coverage as the
media turns into its usual circle of
self-reflection that's where i come in
that's my job
see i figure the news is really 30
minutes total
or the same time it takes jimmy failure
to steal a jacket from a homeless [ __ ]
but like a vegas casino cable news never
closes which is why commentary rules if
it weren't for bozos like me you would
have a lot of silence
but when i was a kid i knew the news was
like 30 minutes in the morning a recap
at lunch another 30 during dinner unless
something big happened like the kennedy
assassination the moon landing or marsha
brady going braless
who could forget that
and life went on as usual we played
outside got tuberculosis and shoveled
snow year-round
cnn changed that now we have pretty much
the same quantity of news but we have to
add a lot of hamburger helper to feed a
family of 330 million or six brian
stelters
cnn showed it was possible possible and
also showed us how it could destroy a
country play the george floyd video two
times an hour for months
and you do more to undermine the fabric
of a country than any foreign
disinformation
why look for good news when you can
binge watch home movies of the worst
moments of your life
one news story becomes like a potato
where you can figure out so many ways to
prepare it aug rotten mashed fried but
usually half baked first you report it
then you wonder how it affects the
economy the climate the disadvantaged
the children the economic climate for
disadvantaged children unless of course
their father is hunter biden
then you turn it back on the media which
is my specialty as the media reports the
story what is the media actually saying
i mean other than it's trump's fault and
you're racist sexist and homophobic
in media commentary we're so high on the
smell of our own farts baked beans or an
aphrodisiac
that is disgusting
but in war we get
poor charlie
but in war we get serious as it gets
ugly we lose the theme music we drop the
cute segments we come in with breaking
news graphics
now it's nearly a month of this nightly
grim routine bomb strikes rubble
refugees the dead rinse and repeat we
can't do much else because none of us
have any real insights except maybe for
kilmeade and that's only because his
male pattern baldness is in the shape of
belarus
sometimes in my job i run across stories
that seem too on the nose so we use
phrases like reportedly or some say like
the waitress who finds a racist note on
a receipt or an actor beaten by trump
supporters at night or the idiot son of
a president losing his laptop somewhere
well that story turned out to be legit
which is why they tried to suffocate it
like rosie o'donnell sitting on a
chihuahua
there were others out of ukraine the
phantom jet fighter downing russian jets
sailors refusing to surrender
but the only thing real that we know of
is the brutality
war is bad and the longer it goes the
worse it gets
but sadly it makes a great miniseries
it's the greatest show on earth if
you're lucky enough to live here and
binge watch it like a netflix offering
but most importantly it revives the old
truth about tv news if it bleeds it
leads
but that just makes me wonder where it's
leading me
i hope someplace else other than world
war
hello
iii
welcome tonight's guest
the only time this press secretary
stretched the truth was claiming to be
five feet tall
america's newsroom co-anchor co-host of
the five and author of the book
everything will be okay god i hope so
now in paperback dana perino
his hair is houdini's nightmare in that
there's no escaping his luscious locks
news contributor and washington times
opinion editor charlie hurt so good
he's got the perfect wardrobe for radio
fox across america host jimmy failure
and finally like a piece of ikea
furniture she's barely holding it
together [ __ ]
i know that was gonna get a laugh fox
news contributor count two
god i'm so excited i have dana she's
dressed in honor of a circus peanut yes
charles your tie is reminiscent of uh
fruit striped gum yes uh you know what
you do when your mother gives you a tie
you wear it
yeah and jimmy you remind me just of a
black and white television we had
yeah it's very sad you're rupert pumpkin
i actually like you the black and white
facial hair growing it well i think i
couldn't shower for two days because i
had no hot water you look like so i
haven't showered in two days and i stink
and i haven't shaved how about that
charlie
uh that's tmi why didn't you check into
a hotel
you know what why do you mind your own
business
charlie i want to go to you first i
haven't talked to you in ages because
you've been away doing god knows what
how do you think the media is doing and
covering the war well you know it's
fascinating and uh great monologue there
because i think
it reminds me you know this all began
back with the gulf war when cnn showed
us the first war on television right and
you could literally sit there i remember
sitting there i was in college at the
time binge watching for literally
48 50 hours at a time yeah and you
couldn't remember get under the desk
bernie yes it was it was it was i mean
we couldn't even believe what a
uh
what an experience it was and you were
there and then you fast forward whatever
that is 30 years to to where we are
today
and it's become
it's sort of become
almost less real in a lot of ways even
though we have a lot more uh ability to
present the truth or present what's
going on there but it's been sort of
corrupted in a lot of ways to the point
where you know you have um it's become
almost like a like a hollywood version
of it all right and and you wind up with
things like french president emmanuel
macron uh you know dressing up like
vladimir zelinski yes and for his next
election because he wants to the the
characters become like uh movie stars i
forgot about that yeah there's an
interesting everybody's fulfilling a
role yeah right you got the villain you
got the hero you got uh the supporting
players and i'm not sure that it's very
good for either the truth or and most of
all i don't know that it's very good for
people the people who are actually
suffering yeah dying and we and and
we're i don't know that we're doing a
very good job of of uh you know you want
to applaud the heroism of the ukrainians
but people are dying yeah and it's a
horrifying assault that they're enduring
and you don't and you've got to sort of
figure out where you celebrate the
heroism without
continuing something that's horrible you
know dana when we do the five i
uh when i sit down at the five with this
topic i have no idea what i'm going to
say because i have like i the more i
read the less i know i don't know who
like i don't know who to believe and i
don't know i don't know who's winning
because they both say they're winning i
don't unders sometimes i think that
ukraine's winning and then i go no it's
already over they lost i don't know how
to deal with it well part of it is that
this if you go back to the gulf war um
in that sort of like 1991
so okay so one of the other things
that's extremely different from then to
now and even from when i was press
secretary to now which is only from 2008
to now is um social media
and that is so so now you actually have
people who are able to provide images
and it's not from cnn it's actually from
people who are their experience in it
for themselves so to me that is the most
believable thing like they have the
phone they're filming it and they have
they like put it out there on their uh
their feed so and there what's
interesting is how elon musk has
provided this ability so that the
internet continues to stay up yeah but
we've never seen that before either and
isis was a different thing that was not
that wasn't now now they did use social
media yeah in order to terrorize but
this is also a little bit different
where you have the victims who are also
recording what is happening yeah yeah
god who isis was the worst with their
daily beheadings jimmy i wish you'd be
heading out there
bang that is such a terrible joke i i
even feel disgusted by what i just said
what is this isis is actually claiming
responsibility for that bomb they just
called the studio
it was us
well done my friend
uh what do you what do you make of this
so far uh your facial hair um
i think you look like the lead singer of
a boy band called in middle school um
i'm kidding i owed you one i love you
you know i do i'm genuinely concerned
obviously for everyone in ukraine it
goes without saying but i want to
qualify that's people don't think of
being cavalier about that but the effect
it has on us in terms of what we're
witnessing in our phone every day i am
concerned we're becoming desensitized
because we're seeing things you're not
supposed to see you know like i grew up
in an era where the only way to see
certain things was to go out and do them
you know what i mean like if you
actually
you know wanted to see someone fight a
stripper you had to show up get past the
bouncer and punch a stripper
now you type it into google now you type
it into google they're like did you mean
a brunette stripper or a blonde strip
you know what i mean and i just feel
like we have too many options at our
disposal
and it's making us more concerned with
demonstrating empathy than having it
that's my concern wow what do you think
cat
about the stripper thing no yeah
i wouldn't say that was an odd example
it was very specific
i wanted to get off war is what i'm
trying to do i appreciate that very
specific in a lot of detail
how biographical sorry if that hit home
okay yeah
so oh yeah i think obviously seeing
these things as you mentioned every
single day
non-stop i think it can also create an
emotional response i mean it should it's
supposed to obviously if you're not a
sociopath it would but when it comes to
your emotions and the impact they can
have on decision making or calling for
certain actions they can be really
careful about making decisions from an
emotional perspective in any case and
especially when you're talking about
something as serious as war and
potentially world war three very good
point thank you it's a rational person
but you know another thing that's really
disturbing about the current situation
is also we've just come off of five
years of a psychotic episode
in the media right where we have seen
them peddle propaganda
i think that's affected me yes yes
completely no it absolutely because it
when i can't trust anything i don't
trust anybody yeah i can't believe
anything it's like i don't know and i
don't know if i'm ever going to get back
to that maybe that's a good thing who
knows
you almost made up for your tie
a notion that reeks of desperation lower
your standards to counter inflation what
a rhyme hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else